salut Val c'est le docteur pet amical
infirmière
maintenant on a plus qu'à examiner ton
bras à l'endroit où le filtre à blessé
les nan ne le sait pas encore qui est
Lena la fille de ta sœur maintenant elle
t'attend
à la récompense qui t'attend ok on a
rien sans rien
[Musique]
tu as été blessé tant de fois ta
carapace et si épaisse qu'est-ce qui
t'est arrivé
qui m'est arrivé
[Musique]
tout le monde de toute ma famille
elle a blessé le chien exprès pour
sortir de chez elle pourquoi tu pleures
c'est qui hein personne
c'est toi sa famille je ne peux pas
faire ça j'ai un travail j'ai une vie
qui m'attend on ne peut pas toujours
choisir la vie qu'on mène
[Musique]
quand j'étais petit c'est souvent moi
qui m'occupais de mes petites sœurs
[Musique]
tu veux qu'on aille où est ton vol ça
peut attendre
[Musique]